racist rants by federal land moocher
cliven Bundy and vile comments
attributed to Los Angeles Clippers owner
Donald sterling and put old-school
racism back in the news but let's get
real
however contemptible Bundy and sterling
aren't what's holding down blacks and
other minorities in today's America
here are three policies that whatever
their original intentions systematically
screw over poor blacks and other
minorities whether it's absurd licensing
laws for at-home hair braiders day care
operators and other small-time
entrepreneurs or minimum wage laws that
price young unskilled black kids out of
their first jobs barriers to the labor
market take their biggest hole on those
with the least education skills and
professional connections created amidst
fears of cocaine snorting Negros opium
smoking Chinese and pot puffing Mexicans
the drug war not only locks up blacks
and minorities in vastly unfair and
unjustifiable numbers
it also concentrates black-market
violence in poor urban neighborhoods
blacks don't use drugs more than whites
they just pay a much steeper price
despite more than doubling real
per-pupil expenditures since the early
1970s
America's graduating high school seniors
have shown no meaningful improvements in
math reading and science it's black and
Hispanic kids in inner cities whose
parents lack any real choice in schools
that suffer the most and yet politicians
teachers and parents who can afford to
exercise choice for their own kids do
everything they can to keep poor kids
trapped in failing schools at a combined
140 years old Bundy and sterling are
survivors from an older uglier America
that died well before the election of
Barack Obama they can go for themselves
but if the rest of us actually want to
address the sort of racism that's
screwing over today's minorities we'd do
better to bust down barriers to work and
the drug war and tear apart the school
monopoly for Reason TV I'm Nicholas